carlos martinez making his second start
took the loss sunday and his line was
five innings four hits four runs they
were earned walked a couple struck out
four
smooth sailing
in the onset of that game and then he
backed off a little bit castiano's got
him but castiano's getting everybody
right now and he is the 2-2
popped up left side
shift was on arenado going out o'neal
coming in to make the catch
and there's one away
christian yelich playing in his 65th
game against st louis
19 career home runs against the redbirds
were they all in the first series in
2019 it felt like it sure did yell its
way 202 coming
swinging a line shot into right of base
hit for christian yelich hanging
breaking ball from carlos martinez
and the brewers have their first base
hit first base runner ahead of avi sayo
garcia this is a slider that stays up
out over the play look at the extension
for yellow see if yellow trunks he does
payoff pitch swinging a miss throw down
to second base is not in time christian
yelich
steals second base
it's a breaking ball thrown by martinez
and slowed things up just enough for
yadier molina and a good throw to second
but yelich got a good break now travis
shaw he has been one of the bright spots
for the milwaukee brewers in a big
opening day at three hits here's shaw
three hits this one grounded
just off the glove of de young in the
shallow left yelich is gonna round
thirty is gonna score
and the brewers have a one nothing lead
travis shaw stays hot as mentioned at
three hits in the opener of the series
on thursday hit that one right off the
glove of paul de young and short
trickled far enough away for the brewers
to cash in turning into a very long
first inning for carlos martinez he is
giving up four singles
struck out one that was garcia runners
go the pitch
swinging ground ball hit sharply at
goldschmidt he's got it takes it to the
bag and the inning is over peterson hit
it hard but right at goldschmidt inning
ends brewers however get a run on four
hits there's adrian hauser sporting the
yellow shoes got the lc greenwood look
today very very nice i'm a big fan of
that first start against minnesota he
got a loss five innings four hits two
runs
yeah for adrian he's had seven
appearances against st louis four of
them starts his only appearance last
year
came out of the bullpen
those
are excellent
you hear the ovation for nolan arnotto
who endeared himself to
his new home fans orinato's hit streak
the longest opened a season by a new
cardinal since roger maris
the 1-2 orinato rips it fair
inside the third base line
thinking two on his way to second diving
in head first with a two-out double
well roger maris has some company now
dan nolan arenado does it again you're
looking for a spark he has been there
each and every time yaddy's stopping at
second
and the first two have reached here in
the home half of the second here's tyler
o'neil
the one-two pitch
get out of play
and the one-two pitch to tyler o'neill
o'neal hits it up the middle but right
into the shift
and they turn two but tyler o'neal
something happened here
yeah this was the pitch before he lines
one up up the middle for the double play
but you see him wins there and you you
look at him here coming out of the box
you can just tell that something is
biting at him can't
can't tell right here where it is nobody
wants to go out there and be the guy to
give up the runs and hauser's pitching
like that today
see what he has in mind here narvaez
inside whoa just tied him up i mean that
sequence right there
if hauser is ever struggling on the
mound just
clip those off
put him in a replay and let him watch it
that's as good as it gets i thought
naraya is going right to it i mean not
only throwing the size down but putting
the target where he wants that baseball
you can see that that target was down
and in it wasn't on the plate ground
ball gobbled up
and the throw to first is in time
that was travis shaw that made that play
excuse me
now guards ceo's over two he's struck
out and bounced to short
that ball is hammered deep into left
center field way back and gone
goodness gracious yeah there you go
a booming home run from garcia
two run blasts it's three nothing
brewers
two seamer down and in and garcia
pulverized it they get the tape measure
out for that one partner boy it had that
sound too didn't it i mean as soon as
you made contact the way that ball
sounded off the bat you knew it was
gonna fly out of here
and it did that is a long home run you
don't see him go that far into the
bleachers very often bases loaded well
all this done with two outs
single by tommy edmond to center
goldschmidt to left a walk to arenado
bases loaded paul the young the stretch
on o2 to paul de young with the bases
loaded
struck him out
to seamer and some emotion from adrian
hauser as he exits towards the brewers
dugout the cardinals leave the bases
loaded in the bottom of the fifth all of
a sudden he got a little bit of life
again justin williams looked for that
big knock
ground ball to first and it gets through
hera
molina will score
they're going to wave in another one
the play at the plate dean is safe at
the plate
loses his helmet
3-2
austin dean scoring all the way from
first in a ball under the glove of hero
austin dean was cooking on this one
justin williams gets a slider serves it
down there that means a routine play for
hiro just slides right under his glove
garcia so runners had first and second
with one out
oh that one's hammered in the left
center down into the gap it goes
bradley will score yell it's on his way
to third he's being waved home throw to
the plate yelich is in there
two runs in
on a double by garcia
and it's 5-2 milwaukee yeah four runs
driven in by abby garcia kesten has
swung it well he's had a tough day in
the field but he has swung it well today
that ball is hammered into center field
hera sending carlson back at the wall
there it goes
kesten hera
a booming home run for the brewer first
baseman
well you know that feels good that's a
three-run shot
he's had his struggles defensively but
there's nothing wrong with that bat well
he's up one now it cost his team two
runs defensively and drove in three with
that swing of the bat wow boy he
had a piece of that the o2 pitch
and dean hammers one down the left field
line will it stay fair it is gone
into big macho
[Applause]
center field deep
bradley
makes the play what a catch
jackie bradley jr had it lined up
leaping into the wall bradley jr a
former gold glove center fielder hauls
it in yeah put a circle around that one
he made the catch crashed against the
wall lost his sunglasses lim bloom
trying to put it away
the pitch
fly ball left field playable for yelich
drifts a couple of steps to his left
pulls it in
and this one is over